-Yesterday we saw one of
the most extraordinarily moments
of Donald Trump's presidency
when the FBI raided the offices
of personal lawyer
Michael Cohen,
and in response, Trump
has completely lost his mind.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It's hard to imagine how
Donald Trump could be in
more legal jeopardy
than he is right now.
Basically, Trump has more legal
problems than Conor McGregor
and just as many concussions.
[ Laughter ]
And yet somehow things got
much worse yesterday for Trump.
-Tonight, a dramatic FBI raid
at the New York office
and hotel room
of Michael Cohen,
The President's
personal attorney
who paid off adult film star
Stormy Daniels for her silence
about alleged affair
with Mr. Trump.
-"The New York Times" also
reporting that the FBI also
seized e-mails, tax documents,
and business records,
and that the records include
communications between
Michael Cohen,
The President's attorney,
and President Trump.
-Federal Prosecutors
in Manhattan obtained
search warrants after a referral
from special counsel
Robert Mueller,
who found evidence
of a potential crime.
-Wow, so, just to recap,
the FBI, an organization Trump
has attacked for months,
raided the office
of Michael Cohen,
his longtime personal fixer,
and seized tax documents,
which he has repeatedly refused
to release related
to campaign finance violations
during the election involving
Stormy Daniels,
the porn star he allegedly
had an affair with,
on a referral from
Robert Mueller,
the special counsel
in the Russia investigation.
This is like the series finale
of a TV show
where they try to tie all the
different plot lines together.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're watching like, "Oh!
It's Michael Cohen
from season one!
What's he doing in this episode?
Ohhhhh!"
If Trump ever goes on trial,
they're gonna call characters
from previous episodes
into the courtroom
like the last episode
of "Seinfeld."
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
"Oh, no, Anthony Scaramucci,
what did I do to you?"
[ Deep voice ]
"No Mooch for you."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Of course,
when news like this breaks,
we can always count on
our calm, rational president
to react in a measured way,
and he once again rose
to the occasion this morning
when he got up bright and early
and tweeted
these reassuring words
to a nation in turmoil...
[ Laughter ]
And then,
less than a minute later,
he added this helpful
follow-up...
[ Laughter ]
So the Feds seize Trump's
communications with his lawyers,
and the next morning,
Trump woke up and screamed
"Attorney-client privilege
is dead!"
What is Trump's strategy here,
to act so guilty the feds will
think he has to be innocent?
[ Laughter ]
You know, the insanity defense
only works after
you've been arrested, right?
[ As Trump ] They can't
arrest me if I'm crazy.
Quick, somebody get me a diaper
I can wear as a hat.
[ Laughter, cheers,
and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] Now,
Michael Cohen isn't just
a peripheral player
in Trump's world.
He's been Trump's loyal fixer
for years,
and he's as close
to Trump's inner circle
as you can possibly get.
And last month,
as the controversy surrounding
the Stormy Daniels story
was intensifying,
Cohen insisted that
he would remain forever loyal
to his boss and that the
hush payment he allegedly paid
went beyond politics.
He told "Vanity Fair"...
Yeah, just a thing a friend
does for a friend.
Like when your buddy forgets
his wallet,
so you pay for his coffee,
except instead of coffee,
it's a porn star, and instead
of forgetting his wallet,
he forgot his wedding vows.
[ Laughter, cheers,
and applause ]
And say what you will
about Donald Trump,
but he's a man who respects
and appreciates loyalty.
A friend like that deserves
nothing less
than mutual admiration
and devotion.
So naturally Trump
did what he does
to all of his most loyal
servants --
he immediately threw him
under the bus.
-That's right.
He said "Ask Michael Cohen."
And it looks like the FBI said,
"Okay."
[ Laughter ]
Now, suffice to say the fact
that federal prosecutors
obtained a warrant to raid
the offices of The President's
personal attorney
and seize communications
with The President
is a huge deal.
It's incredibly rare and must
meet a high legal burden.
While the exact details of
the warrant are still unknown,
yesterday, we started to learn
more about which
potential crimes investigators
might be looking into.
-Wow! It's amazing how many
different crimes the Trump team
has been able to cover.
You got Michael Cohen
on bank fraud,
wire fraud,
and campaign finance violations,
Paul Manafort on failing to
register as a foreign agent,
Michael Flynn
on lying to the FBI,
and Jared Kushner for, I don't
know, probably using a fake ID.
[ Laughter ]
[ High-pitched, raspy voice ]
Hi, I'm 21.
I work at the White House.
I'd like to buy some beer,
please.
Do you have to buy six,
or can you get one or two?
[ Normal voice ] And here's a
fun fact I learned yesterday --
Michael Cohen's office,
the one that was raided
by the FBI, is actually located
at 30 Rockefeller Plaza.
That's the building
we are in right now,
The one we tape this show
in every day.
I feel like Dorothy
in "The Wizard of Oz."
Everything I was looking for was
right there with me all along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Michael Cohen was very much
the keeper
of Trump's
most closely held secrets,
and the fact that FBI
raided his office
and seized his communications
with Trump is being taken
by outside lawyers as a sign
of just how serious
the investigation is.
One lawyer told
"The Washington Post"...
And if there's anyone
who knows the worst about Trump,
it's his barber.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Cohen may very well know
more about Donald Trump
than any other being
on the planet,
which might explain why in
his first comments to the media
yesterday after the story broke,
Trump seemed to come
totally unglued.
He was supposed to meet
with his national security team
to discuss Syria,
but completely unprompted,
he began the meeting
by attacking the FBI.
-So, I just heard that they
broke into the office of
one of my personal attorneys.
-They broke in? They're the FBI.
They had a search warrant.
That's like waking up from
surgery and telling your doctor,
"You stole my appendix!"
Trump once again aired one of
his long-simmering grievances,
his anger at Attorney General
Jeff Sessions,
who recused himself
from the Russia investigation
because he has misled Congress
and because he had been a part
of the campaign that was
being investigated.
Trump wants someone in charge
who will exert influence
over the probe and potentially
shut it down,
and he made that clear again
yesterday.
-The Attorney General made
a terrible mistake when
he did this and when he recused
himself, or he should have
certainly let us know if he was
going to recuse himself
and would have put a different
Attorney General in.
-I shudder to imagine who else
Trump would have named
as Attorney General --
Chris Christie, Rudy Giuliani,
an Amazon Echo
that only watches Fox News.
-[ Amazon Echo voice] Hillary.
Obama. Deep state. Witch hunt.
E-mails. E-mails. E-mails.
E-mails. E-mails.
-Heeey!
Trump was so panicked
and flustered when he spoke
to the media that he just
kept mindlessly repeating
the same words over and over.
-It's a disgraceful situation.
-It's a disgrace.
It's frankly a real disgrace.
I think it's a disgrace.
It's a disgrace.
I think it's disgraceful.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, man, if you are not
going to bother to read
the Constitution,
could you at least check out
a thesaurus?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] You look at
what's going on, it's...
ignominious.
[ Normal voice ] Oh. Okay.
We'll give you credit for that.
One of the most unsettling
things about Trump's comments
was they were made at a meeting
where Trump was supposed
to be deciding whether to use
military force against Syria.
In fact, sitting next to him
was his new National Security
Advisor John Bolton.
And Trump noted the awkward
timing of his arrival.
-John, I want to thank you
very much.
This is gonna be a lot of work.
Interesting day. He picked today
as his first day, so, Generals,
I think he picked the right day.
-No, he didn't.
[ Laughter ]
This is like starting your job
at Enron on the day
of the crash.
"Oh, you must be the new guy.
Here, grab a shredder."
[ Laughter ]
This is one of the most
consequential
and potentially most perilous
moments in the Trump presidency.
One of his closest confidants is
in the cross hairs of the FBI,
and he's openly threatening
to shut down
the special counsel's
investigation.
And if that happens,
I can think of at least one word
I'd use to describe
the situation.
-It's a disgrace.
Disgrace. Disgrace.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪